do you feel a responsibility to stay
thick kind of um yeah you know what I do
every time like a famously fat person
loses weight it does feel like a
betrayal I will admit that uh but I
think I could lose 100 pounds and still
be generally thick you know what I mean
so it's like I just wanna I want to trim
it down a little bit I want to get a
little I want to get it uh you know
going a little bit but yeah I can never
be a skinny guy like you see like Fat
Joe lit the man's name is Fat Joe he's
Zed up right now yeah he is [__] his
humongous head skinny as you can't be
skinny man you can't take the OIC that
far get a adjust your dose have a little
[__] have some chichiron and [__]
stay you know big arms little titties
that's my dream just I just want little
titties I don't want them to go away
yeah oh
yeah no I would like little arms big
titties on a G oh you know what not even
little arms big arms little titties is a
[__] move though on a woman yeah yeah
I've seen some hot big armed little
titti ladies big armed little titty baby
that's somebody raised in a mount on a
mountain yes yes B yeah climbing up
somebody got to go uphill pull
themselves up a lot absolutely thick
very very like the the tips of their
finger Al basically Albanian soup
fingers Albanian soup
stirrers thick Knuckles you know what I
mean maybe bales of hay that type that
that style of [__] although I have not
I haven't Tangled with too many country
girls I'm open to it but it's just never
you know I'm not around them I guess I'd
love a southern I'd love to hear a
Southern accent while you know busting
would be cool I'm sure you've done your
fure yeah oh my go oh my my my go roll
TI somebody said one of my friends said
that he [__] a girl from the south and
she said she was fixing to come oh yeah
that sounds I would love to hear that to
come F to come I would be like that's
awesome take your time what it would do
yeah what it would do for me was I would
hear fixing to come and I would both get
the rush of a woman saying she's about
to come but just that phrase would make
me in my head smell biscuits and think
about biscuits and think about other
like Southern traditions and I think it
would be a very powerful fix I'll a
couple of Scoops at to
come if you're fixing it if you're
fixing to come well I've never had to
come before put some cheese on it baby
I'll have a little of it yeah not much
you know yeah all we ate a little bit
ago what have you ever been fat at all
in your life I had a couple months where
I was fat something happened I don't
remember and uh what ages oh I got in a
wheelchair oo [__] for what I got in a
wheelchair dude I got my pendix taken
out I was running the bases I was doing
baseball oh [__] right my P burst or
whatever as a child oh my God and our
coach right it was like just some guy he
was just so fat he just hated gay people
right that can
happen he was
like your your brain gets so fat it cuts
off the empathy part of your brain so
anybody different than you you want to
just [__] you know you wanted to kill
him absolutely yeah and he would like
try to point to a base and he couldn't
even [__] he was always like he has to
do a full body
point he was like a duck he was like
John McCain duck hunting you know he
just he just [__] go ahead make my
day John MCC try to [__] just do it
at uh four degrees or under yeah yeah
having to do like glute Bridges to raise
the
gun you get there and you can go on that
track or you can just walk you know what
I'm talking about with the moving floor
yes of course and you just like you just
get on that moving floor and you just
you're not even really thinking about
your steps no you're just you know but
it does feel cool I will say it is sorry
to muddy up the analogy no it's nice but
feel fast as [__] when I like you go on
those and you I even pick up the pace
and I'm like I'm [__] Superman I'm
bionic oh you go fast you'll walk on
them oh wow love that feel you feel so
fast yeah oh you feel like you're in a
threesome I feel like no that for me
historically that's uh nervous blowing
it you know having the worst time in my
life uh I've had I've had I've had a
nice one but most of them been brutal
what city you have a nice one in Chicago
okay and the one in New York but yeah
had some bad had ones a couple other
places oh you've been in a multi
multitude of them been in a couple yeah
my I I ended my special with uh did we
talk about this last time it feels like
we did remember cuz I feel like you were
in one I was in a unique one outside of
Missouri one time we talked about it we
talked about it grateful everybody made
it out
okay to be honest you know it's just
yeah but if you're crushing it if you're
crushing in threesome that's probably
what that feels like well my thing was I
didn't know one of the girls so I like
was trying to small talk while I was
hooking up with this other girl so like
it was like hey where are you from you
know oh you have family and you're just
Mak it just the whole thing was just
ridiculous I think you just got to turn
that brain off brother when you're when
the dick is hard the brain is off that's
that's I think how it needs to be oh my
that has been my number one problem I
remember when I used to be able to smoke
weed sometimes my erection cuz my brain
would shut off yes and my erection dude
it would be like oh my God it would be
like somebody that had gotten to the to
the top of a hill for the first it's
life oh my God this this view is
unbelievable it stayed up there was
doing
selfies yeah dude I'm with you too that
is always my problem because I when I
actually like a girl the first time I
[__] her I have been hard 0% of the time
because I'm worried I'm going to blow it
but then if I don't get if it's like you
know just we both know the score we're
just here to bust no problems dick wise
and then again if I break through and
I've been dating somebody for a while
and I trust you know all that all the
like anxiety of like does this person
like me all this [__] when that truly
goes away not just intellectually but I
feel it's going away my dick actually
truly gets hard really and then we broke
literally this happened to me where I
dated somebody and we finally I felt
like we finally got all our [__] figured
out and my dick was getting harder than
ever to the point where she was like
what's up with your dick like she was
literally like something's different
your dick is like actually she was
like she was like m toally uncomfortable
the first for the first time ever having
sex with me she was like your dick has
gotten not small anymore like that was
essentially not big not big but not
small you know and then literally we
broke up it felt good it felt good
feeling positive yeah yeah man the
that's I I I've NE I never try and work
through that uncomfortable phase to see
if there's a real phase on the other
side it's so hard for me man I it's
scary I for me too that's the only girl
I've ever done it with and I will tell
you this it took a while to like get
over that but once it happened it felt
awesome and like I've been too busy the
last couple years like I don't feel like
a I don't know if you feel this way but
it's like on the road constantly and
shooting a special and working on other
projects I don't even feel like a person
like I barely see my friends I barely
see my family you can't have a dating
life because you're just not in a
[__] City for longer than whatever
and so I'm really looking forward to try
to like focusing on that [__] in the
next year I'm taking most of the next
year off wow really stuff yeah I can't I
can't be a yeah I can't like from St
from the road anyway like I'll do local
[__] I'll work on my act and I'm G to
say you know you lose a lot of money
doing that but it's like what do you
have the money for yeah um but yeah dude
I would say give it a whirl it's worth
it because I felt it w and you know it
ended up we weren't right for each other
for other reasons but you know when you
get when your dick gets hard from love
that's special oh wow you know that's a
special thing yeah I want that I think I
think you can have it you're a wonderful
guy a a girl would be lucky to have your
truly hard dick uh anxiety free
oh can't even imagine that really I know
it is hard to imagine when it happened
to me I was so I was like what's going
on here no way yeah I can't imagine like
getting like having a natural like just
being yeah
rehard I'm rehe
harded I'm a rehard
yeah
dude the way you know you're in love
when you [__] like a
reard yeah I do not I am like a sniper I
literally have to get my wiener hard run
in there I'm like go go go you're
getting the signal I'm like a Navy SEAL
dude shout out my friend ler but I had
to get out I would have to get erect run
in there do the damage and then
yeah yeah yeah slip out yeah yeah yeah I
mean before the gates even closed I'd
have to make it back
out